back everyone we continue with our
election coverage here at 623
and many races here in nevada are still
too close to call
so this morning as we scroll through the
results both on the bottom of the screen
and hear full screen in a second keep in
mind
it's hard to know for sure how many
mail-in ballots are still left to count
by election officials but with that in
mind
let us take a look at the clark county
commission races we start with district
a
democratic incumbent michael naft he
leads republican challenger michael
thomas there for that seat
district b clark county commission chair
marilyn kirkpatrick
she appears headed to a pretty easy
re-election there over
kevin williams district c is razor thin
current las vegas city councilman
stavros anthony
and former nevada secretary of state
ross miller are essentially tied right
now
anthony is trying to become the first
republican on the clark county
commission
since bruce woodbury left back in 2009
let's look at district d now democrat
william mccurdy is sailing to an easy
win
over david washington now two of
nevada's four congressional races have
been officially called for the winners
this morning
democrat dana titus easily won
re-election over republican joyce
bentley
that's nevada's